يا ليلى
يا ليلى هات الصابونة  ***  نفرك رغوتها بأيدينا
وووش ووش تحت الماء ***  رغوتها تكبر تحمينا
رغوتها تكبر تحمينا
غسل دقيقة قد ينقذنا   ***  وتكون الصحة مضمونة
قد نلمس بعض الأشياء ***  تحمل فيروسا يعدينا
تحمل فيروسا يعدينا
يا ليلى هات الصابونة   ***  نفرك رغوتها بأيدينا
وووش ووش تحت الماء ***  رغوتها تكبر تحمينا
رغوتها تكبر تحمينا
قد نركض في أي فناء ***  أو نلعب لعبه تسلينا
فلتصبح عادتنا دوما *** لو نفرغ نغسل أيادينا
لو نفرغ نغسل أيادينا
يا ليلى هات الصابونة ***  نفرك رغوتها بأيدينا
وووش ووش تحت الماء ***  رغوتها تكبر تحمينا
رغوتها تكبر تحمينا
يا ليلى ما أحلى الصحة *** في المنزل بين أهالينا
صحبتهم في كل مكان *** دوما هي أغلى أمانينا
دوما هي أغلى أمانينا
يا ليلى هات الصابونة ***  نفرك رغوتها بأيدينا
وووش ووش تحت الماء ***  رغوتها تكبر تحمينا
رغوتها تكبر تحمينا